[MUSIC PLAYING]
ESTEBAN DE LA CANAL:
My name is Esteban.
I'm the lead of the
profilings in Android Studio,
and today I'm going to show you
all the new features we have
in Android Studio 3.2 and
some of the features that we
launched in Android Studio
3.1 in the profilers.
Right.
So I'm going to be doing a
demo for most of the session,
but just in case you haven't
seen the profilers before--
just to get an idea, how many
of you have used the profilers?
OK.
That's great.
Well, I was going
to explain that we
have these profilers to you,
but most of you have seen them.
But we have a new
profiler that I'm
going to be introducing today.
That is the energy profiler.
As you know, we
have the monitors
that show you light
telemetry from the app.
We have the CPU network memory,
and the new energy profiler.
And you can dive into any
of those, and, for example,
inspect your
network request, see
where you made a
request from code,
see what you actually
downloaded, what was sent.
You can also dive into
the memory profiler,
see the breakdown
of the memory, see
how many objects
you have allocated,
where you allocated them.
You can also dive
into the CPU profiler.
I'm going to be showing you
some new cool features that we
added there in 3.2,
specifically systrace.
Again, I'm going to ask the
question, how many of you
have used systrace before?
OK.
Cool.
Now systrace is-- we
started with the first steps
of integrating systrace into
the Android Studio CPU profiler.
I'm going to be demoing
that in a few moments.
And last but not least is
the new energy profiler
that will guide you in
finding problems in your app
that could lead to energy
profiling-- energy issues.
I talk more about that at
the end of the session.
And with that, that's it.
That's all the
slides that I have.
So I'm going to move
to the demo now.
And I have to make a disclaimer.
So all the features that I'm
going to be demoing today,
I am Android Studio
3.2 Canary, and there
is a reason why they are not
in the stable release yet.
So we might be in
for a bumpy ride,
but I wanted to show
you what we have.
And you know, if it
crashes we'll just
keep it between us and
people watching on YouTube
and that's it.
All right.
So I wrote last
week this clock app.
It's a simple clock
app that has the clock.
It has a stopwatch that you can
click and it does something.
And it has a timer.
And I want to profile
it with you guys.
So let's first start
with network profiler.
So this app has a lot
of features that a clock
app should not have.
For example, it needs
internet access.
It needs to access location.
It has a lot of things
so we can demo this.
So please do not write
the clock app like this.
So one of the features it has is
you can change the background.
So if the internet
connection is good enough,
this thing is going to start
downloading some images right
now.
There we go.
You can dive in into
the network profiler.
You surely have
seen this before.
And you can see all the network
requests that have been done.
You can click on them and
see the actual payload.
Something new that
was added in 3.1
is the ability for us
to see what we send,
not just what we
receive, but we can
see the payload or the
custom headers that we use.
In this case, I have
one custom header
that says Google I/O. There
is another new feature in 3.1
for the network profiler,
and that is the threads view.
So as you see here, we
show you the request
in a timeline, but if you choose
threads view, what you can see
is on which thread--
let me close this, so
we have more space.
There we go.
So you can see each request
on which thread it was made.
And if we have more like this.
I'm using a standard
asynchronous task, which
uses a default executer that
will run them sequentially,
and you can see them.
And if they were
reusing the same thread,
you can see them too.
But if in your app, you have a
more complex threading request,
you can use this view
to see what's going on.
So those are the
two new features
on the network profiler
that we've added in 3.1.
And now I'm going to move
to the memory profiler.
Let me go to the next session.
If you have seen
this view before,
we split up how
much memory you're
using into different
components, but we also
show you the number of
objects you have allocated.
If you are profiling on an
Android or your phone or newer,
we have--
and this is super cool-- we have
a feature called live location
tracking.
Remember back in the day--
it was probably last year--
when you had to do
a location tracking,
you had to click on a button
to record the locations
and then you would see them.
Well, if we wanted to
know what happened here,
we can see that the
object line going up,
as being garbage
collector is going up,
as being garbage collected.
So if you want to see what's
happening, just select a range,
and we will have the information
of every single object that
was allocated there, at
which time it was allocated,
and where in your code.
It was allocated.
And you can slide
this window and you
can see this thing changing.
So if I slide it over a
garbage collection period,
you will see which
objects were deallocated
Let me close this window.
There we go.
We can see that there was a
lot of strings deallocated.
So we can start actually
having a look at this app
and see how bad it is written.
For example, if I
select this and I
want to see what
was allocated, I
can see that there were a
lot of strings allocated.
I can click on any one of those
and see where I allocated them,
and I allocated them
inside an onDraw.
This is not a good idea.
If you have a custom view and
you allocate a lot of strings
there, bad things will happen.
And we'll see more about that
through the CPU profiler.
But this is already
starting to tell us
signals about what my
app is doing wrong.
Another new thing
that we added in 3.2
is the ability to see
JNI global references.
This is very important
because a lot of memory leaks
occur because one JNI
global reference is created,
and then we don't know when
we created it and we don't
know where it is.
So when you select a range,
what we have here in my app,
every time I download an image,
I run a filter through it
in C++ to darken it so
the font can be seen.
And I have a global
reference there.
And I hope I did it right.
So we have a special heap,
which we call the JNI heap,
but when you select
it, you can see
all the global references that
existed in this range of time.
In this case, I have
this entry, and I
know I created one but
it should have been gone.
So let me go live here
and select a range.
And here it is.
This is my global--
this is every image
that I've downloaded.
I'm still holding a JNI
global reference to it.
And I can actually navigate
to the C++ line of code when I
created that global
reference I never let go.
So I hope this is useful
to track down problems
with global references.
And one more thing.
You probably have been seeing
all the time on the left
that we have a new panel
called the Sessions panel.
Well, now we allow you
to see previous sessions
that you have been profiled,
so you can navigate back
and compare previous runs.
If you're working on
optimizing your app,
and say, what did I
change, you can go back
and see through the sessions.
Well, at the end of
the demo, hopefully we
can go back and see what we
optimized and what happened.
But that opened the door for
us to do things like this.
Now we can import a file.
I'm going to import a heap dump.
And this heap dump is
being imported directly
to the new profilers,
and it creates
what we call a fixation
for it, and you
can analyze the
heap dump as you're
used to in the profilers.
You can also import
traces for CPU.
And everything we can
export, we can import too.
So that's pretty handy
on-- this is new in 3.2.
And this is what I wanted
to show for memory.
And now we're going to go to
CPU and spend most of the time
there.
Right.
This is the live session.
And I'm going to show you
one feature that you have.
All right.
So one thing that
we wanted to add
was the ability to profile
since the beginning.
So if it is a profile,
you know this,
and if you want to
profile your app start,
you have to go to CPU profiler
and click record so you
can see what's happening.
Well, in 3.2, what you can do is
if you go to the Profiling tab,
we have an option that
says start recording
a method trace on startup.
So I have this dex.
You can choose the
configuration that you want.
In this case, I'm going to use
a sample Java configuration,
and I'm going to rerun the app.
Cool.
Now, you can see that
the app restarted.
The profilers to me directly
to the CPU profiler,
and there is already
a capture in progress
from the very
beginning of the app.
So I'm going to stop
it now, and we're
going to investigate
what happened there.
Let's take a few
seconds to get the data.
Cool.
I don't know if you can see
the resolution on the screen,
but let's have a
look and see that.
I'm going to select the
very beginning of the app.
In fact, you can see that
the capture has started
even before our telemetry
could start getting data
from the app, right?
Our telemetry started here,
but the app started before,
and we can see the data.
And if we keep
zooming in there, you
can see the first onCreate
of my main activity.
And even before that we
can see, one of the dexes
were lowered at the very,
very beginning of your app.
So with this mechanism you can
profile from the very beginning
and optimize the startup
time of your app.
But let's have a
look at this capture
and see if those strings
we saw before are actually
causing some problems.
One of my favorite views
in the CPU profiler
is the Flame chart.
The Flame chart aggregates
all the call stacks
that have the same beginning.
So you can see it's
basically the top-down tree,
but in a visual way.
And you can see that one of the
biggest things is my onDraw.
The way I roll this
out is on every frame
I'm rendering everything again.
That's not a good
way of doing it,
but it's a really good
example for the profilers.
So you can see
that I'm rendering,
and there is a lot of
things at the top that have
to do with string formatting.
And this could be the
source of our string problem
that we saw before.
So it's another symptom that
your app is not doing well.
One thing that I always say
about our profilers is that we
cannot really tell you
what's wrong in your app.
We can only tell you
what your app is doing,
and then it's up
to you to say, oh,
I didn't expect this to happen.
Because as you can see, my app
looks fine, but under the hood
it's not.
So let's say you have a bug
on a label that you put wrong,
and it's in a
different position.
You're running your app.
You see it there, and
say, oh, it's wrong.
I need to fix this.
But if you have something like
a performance issue wrong,
you won't see it.
You won't see it until even--
we'll talk about battery later,
and you will see it
in the field, right?
So we want our profilers to
be another window to your app,
so that you can run your app
while seeing the profilers
and then you see the problems
there because something
that you did not expect
starts showing up,
like me doing a lot of string
formatting inside an onDraw
call.
So let's go to the
code, where I have my--
can you see?
Yeah.
So I have my onDraw, and I have
a function called drawtime,
where I draw the
time on my app, and I
have wrote a function
called drawTimeString
that uses string formatting
to draw the time,
and that is probably
not a good idea.
So that's just a
single incident.
I have another
function that writes--
that draws the time
without using strings,
and we're going to try it.
Oh, before we do
that, let me show you
one thing that we have here.
So, how many of you are
familiar with this line
of code, Trace.beginSection?
Do a raise of hands.
Cool.
So what this line does,
together with the end section,
they will create
a systrace event
that you can use
systrace to see.
So before I make
my optimization,
I'm going to show
you what happens
if I take a capture using
the system trace method.
So this is running
systrace under the hood,
and you don't have to
go to the Python script
anymore and get it, and then
get it back on the HTML view.
We will instead show
it to you right here
in our app in Android studio.
OK.
Remember what I mentioned
about the bumpy ride?
This is it.
Oopsie.
Let me restart the emulator,
and we'll will do it again.
There we go.
Please, please try this at home.
File bugs, we will fix them.
And when we get this
table, these issues
will be all sorted out.
There we go.
I'm going to go to the CPU
profiler, and use system trace.
Second time's the charm.
OK.
So we have system trace here.
Let me select and zoom
into the selection.
Cool.
One thing that you notice
here, that first of all, we
have a new section there
called the kernel section
where we show you all the CPUs.
And if you pay
close attention, we
re-render all the
thread information,
getting all the
data from systrace.
So before there's
thread information,
we get sampling the
prog file system.
So it's not very accurate.
But as soon as you take
a systrace capture,
you can see exactly where--
what your thread is
doing at every moment.
And more than that, if
I select one of those,
we highlight above on which CPU
your thread is being scheduled.
So you can look at
thread contention
or all those things that are
kicking you out of the CPU.
There is a
fundamental difference
in the way we show systrace
here with the way you see it
in the HTML view.
Here we focus on your app.
So everything here that
is highlighted green,
even the dark green
is just your app.
You can still go and
see the other events
and see what is taking CPU or
where you're being kicked out,
but we focus on your app.
We show you the
threads of your app,
so you don't have to navigate
that gigantic HTML page.
And we use all the other
things that you know about,
all the other captures.
We use them for systrace,
for example, Flame chart
or a top-down view.
So let me zoom in
the moment in time.
There we can see our frames.
So I have here--
let me zoom in more and choose
actually my main thread.
There we go.
So we can see the
ChoreographerduFrame,
and further down, we can see the
onDraw on my custom component,
and we can see the draw time.
Remember in the code-- let me go
back to the code and show you.
In draw time, we
have clock draw time
around the section
around my temp string,
and you can see that I'm
rendering it three times, one
for every section
of my app, and we
can see how long each one
of those is taking, right?
So I'm taking 38 milliseconds
to render a frame.
If you want your app to run
that on 60 frames per second,
you have to render under
17-ish milliseconds.
Now, I'm way over that.
In fact, one of my goals to draw
time is taking 11 milliseconds.
So what I have is
not doing well.
It looked OK, but imagine you
ship this and people complain.
This is one of the things
that I was mentioning about.
You look at your
app, but look at it
through the profiler glass
to see if it's doing OK.
Now let's optimize, and take
another systrace capture.
I'm going to change the
implementation of draw time.
Now instead of
using the strings,
I'm using my custom formatting.
Instead of using
the string format,
I'm using my custom formatting.
We'll run it again
with these changes,
and we'll run it
through systrace
and see how that
affected my app.
Cool.
There it is.
When I go to CPU profiler,
systrace is chosen for me.
And I'm starting a capture.
Just a few seconds
should do because there
are a lot of frames
that happen in there.
Cool, and we have it here.
Right.
Main thread selected.
Zoom into a specific frame.
We have the ChoreographerduFrame
in the framework,
and then it goes down
to the clock onDraw.
And you cannot see any more
the draw time functions
because they are tiny,
tiny specks down there,
each one of them now
taking 71 microseconds,
and the onDraw is
13 milliseconds now.
Woo-hoo.
So we did that.
Now I'm still under
60 frames per seconds
because my app is
bad in other places,
but at least we
optimized one part of it.
Cool.
And that's systrace.
And let me mention
again sessions.
So remember I said, you
can go back and compare.
Well, I have my previous
sessions here on the left,
and we can see the previous
systrace run that we did.
So here it is.
I can select it again, and
look at the main thread
and see how bad my time was.
And then I go back to the
currently running session,
and you can keep all of this.
And of course, if
you right-click,
you can export the trace
and send you on debug,
or on a heap dump, you can
export these things right here
from the Session panel.
Well, let me click this.
Right.
And that's our--
twenty minutes-- that's
our integration with systrace.
So there is another way
of capturing CPU data.
And that is through an
API in the debugger.
Let me go to a line of code.
Here it is.
So I have my stopwatch,
and I'm going
to change it so every time
that I start my stopwatch,
I'm going to run
start method tracing,
and every time
that I stop it, I'm
going to stop method tracing.
I need to import the debuggers,
and I'm going to rerun the app.
Now before this,
once you run the API,
you have to go and
fetch this file
and open it in either any
of your favorite profilers
that can open a trace file.
But right now if I'm
in the CPU profiler
and I use my stopwatch,
this is what happens.
So now I'm taking a capture
and the studio profiler's
detected that a capture's
been taking place,
and we're showing you this.
And when I stop it, I
don't need to go and fetch
the file from anywhere.
We pull it from the device
and we show it right there.
So if I start and I stop,
and I start and I stop,
all this captures.
They're actually
overwriting each other
because they use the
same filing device,
or pulling it and
showing them on Studio.
So that's super handy
when you want to profile
exactly a moment in time.
You can navigate to all of
them, and you can see them here
in the Sessions panel.
That's pretty cool.
One more thing we added in 3.1,
another way of capturing CPU
usage using the C++ sampling
tool called Simpleperf.
If you go to the documentation
in androiddevelopers.com,
you will find documentation
about Simpleperf.
We have a version of Simpleperf
inside Android Studio and it
allows you to sample C++ code
and see the entire call stack
of your C++ program.
I'm not going to demo that
because I don't have a lot
of C++.
Cool.
So that's CPU profiling.
And let me move to the
energy profiler now.
So energy is tricky.
Energy is tricky because there
are two main sources that
use energy on your phone.
Well, the screen is obviously--
I'm not even
counting the screen.
The screen is bad.
It uses a lot of energy, but
the user is using the phone.
So if you're using
a game, right, it's
all the time using the screen.
But the battery drain
problems usually
happen when we use CPU or
network when the user is not
aware of this, or maybe when
we as developers are not
aware of this.
So let me go live.
I'm using a fair amount
of CPU on this app.
And if I go into
the energy profiler,
we classify this as a
light use of energy.
We would show you here
things that-- this
is a really good model, right?
So we show things that represent
how much energy you would
be using on a modern phone.
I'm not refining how much
energy the emulator is
using obviously, but
this is for us to see.
OK, I'm doing well or
I'm not doing well.
I'm going to show you some
things that show up here.
But obviously the two big
factors are CPU and network.
And it's not, you know--
the obvious thing is OK,
just don't use CPU
and network, but how?
Or why am I using
that in the field?
And the problem is not
actually when we use it.
The problem is that we
don't know we're using it.
So let's say I have a wake
lock that runs run amok,
and we don't know where it
is, and that's using CPU.
Or I have an alarm that
I didn't set up correctly
and that is waking my app, and
I'm making network requests.
So it's not about
the actual energy.
It's about all these things that
you could be doing incorrectly
that could cause battery
drain in the long term.
And this is part of what
I was saying before,
that if you look at your
app, if you look at my app,
it seems to be running.
It seems to be fine.
If I were to push this
up to the Play Store
and you started
it on your phone,
this is going to be the most
expensive, battery-speaking,
clock you ever
have on your phone.
I'm going to drain
your battery, right,
and I don't know it
when I'm seeing this.
So by looking at
the profilers, we
can see that constantly
this is draining CPU,
and we can start
investigating why.
Like I said, the
common mistakes are
I have a wake lock that I don't
release, or I have an alarm.
So we wanted to give
you a window so you
can see the things happening.
The same way if you have a
label in the wrong place,
you can see it, we
want to show you
if you have an alarm
that you didn't cancel,
or you have an alarm
in the wrong place,
we're going to show you that.
So let me show you this piece
of my app where I have a timer.
So here, I can run let's
say a 10-second timer.
And you can see the bottom
of the energy profiler,
that there is a yellow
line that showed up.
If I put the tool tip on it,
that's an alarm or a job.
We show you both there.
And you can see that
when the timer stopped,
the alarm went away.
And if I start the timer
again, again I have the alarm.
And this, actually when
I was developing this,
was useful for me to see,
OK, am I doing it right?
When I stop the timer,
does my alarm go away?
When I start it again,
do I call it back?
So this allows you to see this.
Please don't use alarms
for a timer on a clock.
I also have a wake
lock on my stopwatch.
Again, don't use wake
lock for a stopwatch.
And you can see that when I
start it, I apply a wake lock,
and when I stop it, I let it go.
And I can see that
it is working fine.
If the red line keeps
going, I have a bug, right?
My app will look the
same, and I will ship it,
and people will have
problems, but you
can see it through this
window that-- whether it's
fine or not.
And we also track locations.
So if you are acquiring
location like I'm doing now,
we have this purple
line that shows you
that your current location.
The emulator has a
really handy feature
that you can actually tell it
when to send a location event.
So in our model, we show
you that that is actually
using energy.
And again, you can see it in the
purple bar, and if I stop it--
there we go-- the
purple bar is gone.
But more than that, as you
are used to in our profilers,
we can select a range
and we can show you
that you had an alarm, that
you had a location request.
If I move back, we can
select the wake lock
and I'll do it in a second.
More than that, I
can show you where
the location was acquired,
which kind of provider--
I'm using a GPS provider,
so we can see that.
We can see the interval times
that I chose when the code--
I triggered it to have a
toggle location that happens
when I click the button.
And if I click on
the alarm, not only
I can see when I set
it the first time,
but when I reset it,
when I cancel it.
So you can see all the
places in the code that
was triggered so I can debug
problems when this is not
happening correctly.
Let me go back
and show you the--
the wake lock, it's right there.
I select.
You can see the wake lock.
And you can see every
time that I started
and I stopped the stopwatch,
I was acquiring and releasing
the wake lock, and you can
see all the call stacks
for when that happened.
So this is the power of this.
This is not to say, OK,
you're using a lot of battery.
Yeah.
I'm again, I want to use
batteries, so it's fine.
The power of this is so that
you can see that your app is
doing what you think is doing.
And if it's not, you
should go in and fix it.
So.
Cool.
That's the energy profiler.
Let me show you one more
thing that I want to show you.
On the left, we have
the Sessions panel.
And let's go back in time.
I can stop the current
session like this.
And then you can click
on older sessions,
and we can start comparing
all the captures that we did,
back from when I
started the talk here,
and this was the
first time we ran it,
and we keep all this information
until you restart Studio.
So you can compare runs.
And let me show
you the last thing,
and I want to close with that.
I'm going to close a
few minutes earlier.
All right.
Like I said before, I'm
rendering every frame.
I'm doing something that
I should not be doing,
that is I'm invalidating
the view all the time,
and that is using a lot of CPU.
So let's go back to
my activity where
I have the code that does this.
So I have my model that
I update every frame,
and then I invalidate
all the time.
My model has the ability to
know when it has changed,
so I'm only going to
invalidate the canvas whenever
something has changed.
And we're going to see
the impact that that has
on energy, CPU, and so forth.
We're in the app again.
There we go.
You can see now that the energy
profiler most of the time
now is below light.
It was above medium before.
We can compare it with
previous sessions.
But of course when
I have to render,
we can see that the energy
usage starts going up.
This is because I'm
rerendering my view every time.
And you can see the effect here.
You can see it on the
memory profiler too,
if I go back to the
memory profiler.
Remember that line that was
going up, up, up, and being
garbage-collected?
That is gone.
I do have some objects
that are being created
and they will be claimed
later, like here,
but it's not as it was before.
Cool.
And let me stop the demo
and go back to the slides.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]